hello everyone how's everybody doing I
hope you're doing better than me today
we're gonna have an exciting day I'm
gonna start out by saying that I
uploaded a book okay for those who are
interested you can download it at rope
hypothesis calm it's a free book game
and it puts you up to speed brings you
up to speed on what this site is about
so it talks about the Rope hypothesis
proposal new vision of the universe and
so yeah it's a new version that you may
want to get acquainted with so that you
know how this universe works
or at least have a different version of
how this universe works and for those of
you who have a second language we would
like to make sure that you contact us at
toca caca
see if I can get this thing up here I'm
not sure why I'm having problems lately
with some of these see if I can get this
thing here I raised it that's what it
was anyways you contact us at toca a car
with kaze okays hotmail.com and we're
gonna send you a file that you can
translate to your native language okay
anyways I've got some good news for you
today some good and some bad news
bad for me really the good news is that
I found an antidote to the corona virus
and yeah it looks like this you know
it's a jalapeno and you put it in your
mouth you know you chew on it and when
the first the teardrop starts falling
down your cheek you're protected and if
you're like me you eat like 10 or 15 of
these per day you know the next morning
you might have some surprises at the
other end
okay so anyways and the bad news is I'm
not feeling good
that's bad news for me I've got a little
bit of a headache and I've been coughing
a little bit so tis the season to be
sick you know this is a transition from
winter to summer every two years or
three years I get a cold or something
oh I hope it's nothing worse than that
okay I hope so I hope you're feeling
better than me anyways
let's get on with the subject matter
today we're gonna start out a little bit
with the coronavirus slash extinction
theory okay we're gonna address that and
then I'm gonna go over waves and the
prism and water how light goes through a
prism into water okay essentially that's
we're going to be addressing those
issues I'll start with comments because
several people make comments I want to
address those comments okay here's the
first one okay says Bill theory of the
extinction of humans is the
disappearance of money and yet he
presents no evidence zero evidence the
disappearance of money no definition
what it is okay so let's address that
first one regarding evidence okay here
it is in science we have no use for
evidence evidence has to do with
convincing people it's what the
prosecutor uses to persuade the jury to
vote in his favor okay so evidence is a
hallmark of religion because it is in
religion where they harp on belief in
science we have no use for belief and so
therefore we have no use for evidence
you can believe whatever you want
what we do in science is we especially
as it relates to physics we what we do
is we present a mechanism then so once
you have a mechanism that you understand
that's the end of science what continues
is religion your belief in whether the
universe works that way or not that's a
separate issue and so we have no use
evidence okay and money is any medium of
exchange who has which has no intrinsic
value and when we talk about intrinsic a
lot of people get confused because they
have this this notion of what intrinsic
means that has to do with exchange value
okay and that's not what we're talking
about we're talking about intrinsic like
I say they're bartering involves only
tangibles which have intrinsic value
that you that it has some use as it is
you know you have no use for dollar
bills okay
it's money and there's it the dollar
bill itself has no use whatsoever we
give it money we in our brains we give
it money but we have no real use for it
other maybe as bathroom tissue you know
it runs that's about it you know I mean
we have no use for dollar bills so as
far as intrinsic dollar bill has no
intrinsic value it only has value in
your mind okay I'm talking about
tangibles which you can use for
something okay that's that and that's
parting okay it's got to be a tangible
that can be used for something and so
yeah here are a few words of religions
just to put his comment in the right
perspective says these are the
four-letter words of religion okay and
yeah we don't talk about something that
is accurate for example okay we don't
care about accurate or precision you'll
see precise there in the second column
at the bottom we don't agree in science
okay we don't vote pay for theories
that's religion and we don't agree for
example the definitions we fight for
them we defend them with sword and
shield yeah or maybe get in the ring and
fight for them that's the way it works
in science we do not agree and say well
let's agree on your definition no no no
no you gotta fight for it there's
something wrong with the definition you
got to try to throw it down you got a
point what the shortcomings of that
definition are and what they will cause
if you use it okay that's important we
rely on Authority a lot of people say
well all those scientists on earth
cannot be wrong well we don't care about
that because if they're all wrong then
mother nature calls them wrong you know
if if you say space-time is something
that's out there if you say that
particles can be of two places at once
and that's what all the scientists on
earth believe because they believe in
quantum and relativity it doesn't make
it so okay so we don't care how many
people again we don't vote for theories
okay and we don't do calculation we
don't use math at all why because
science is not about describing you see
it or describe there no science is about
explaining and you can't explain what
math math and an equation is only a
description okay so no use for
calculations no use for equations right
and people say what do you say yeah yeah
this is a different sight okay so if you
just came here for the first time and
you came with all these ideas that these
ideas that you got from high school and
college where science is about but
predicting and observing and describing
equations none of that has any value
here all that belongs to religion far as
we're concerned okay why because science
is about explaining in physics we have
to explain mechanisms once you
understand mechanisms science is over
what continues from there on Deficit
from there on is religion your belief
and whether you proved it to yourself
whether you verified something in your
own personal opinion all that stuff has
to do with biases with subjectivity okay
and technology has nothing to do with
science okay so whether something is
useful they let are you there or
something works the letter W there ya
useful or works has nothing to do with
science we don't care if it works some
people say well you wouldn't have a
computer fit if quantum were wrong they
come up with these
sense notions and ya know a computer
does not prove that a particle can be at
two places at once
it's the theory that's ridiculous and
irrational that quantum proposes and you
have people like Richard Feynman Nobel
Prize 1965 you have people like is it
Susskind Leo Susskind from Stanford
University so-called fizzes a
mathematical physicist mathematician and
all these people tell you in your face
that they don't understand their own
theories and people don't understand
that they say no of course you
understand your theories because
otherwise we wouldn't have a computer we
wouldn't have GPS no one thing has
nothing to do with the other GPS does
not confirm that relativity is correct
or the Einstein was correct GPS only was
developed by trial and error okay and
until people understand that they won't
understand anything the fact that GPS
worse does not mean that there is a
physical entity out there called
space-time that is warped and compels
the photons to swerve okay that's the
issue the issues the theory has nothing
to do with the technology science is
about theories not about useful stuff
that work ok so let's get those things
right that's why a lot of people find
this site a little hard to swallow
because there they come out of college
in high school believing in the notion
of of mathematical physics of science of
mathematical physics and you have to
understand how we got here you know we
got here that way because mathematicians
develop science so-called science used
to be called natural philosophy they
developed the long equations they
thought they were gonna figure out how
this universe works by doing experiments
and measuring and coming up with
equations all that has to do with
descriptions
has nothing to do with explaining how
mother nature does her daily work you
know gravity light magnetism etcetera
okay so let's keep that in mind this
site is about how the universe works we
don't care about your math we don't care
about your calculations your
measurements none of that we can erase
all that from the history books it
wouldn't matter at all we need to figure
out how Mother Nature does gravity and
for that there's only one way and that's
figuring out what invisible entities she
uses as mediators period so what we have
to do is figure out what she's using
that's it you know what entities she's
using to do gravity etc okay so what's
the issue here we have also in relation
to what this fellow said you know what
is value and and do we have any use for
value si si what I call Disneyland
economists economists you have a couple
of them very famous guys all of them
you've probably heard of them these are
all Disneyland economists they have no
place in in real economics okay so if
you studied these guys in college or
heard about them or you know look them
up all these people talk about value and
you know that mother nature has no use
for value the only thing mother nature
cares about is the natural economy okay
that's different than all this
artificial economy that all these guys
dealt with natural economy has to do one
thing and one thing only that's food
okay and there's a simple test that you
can run I called the bill Goethe dog
test okay you go to the bank okay listen
carefully now go to the bank and you
borrow a million dollars okay and I'm
sure they'll give it to you no problem I
mean you're just gonna borrow it for
fifteen minutes
they shouldn't have any objection okay
and then you go in there and you get a
hot dog
hey hey little hot dog so you get a
million dollars you get a hot dog and
what do you do with them well you bring
your dog and you ask them and you put
them separate about a meter apart and
find out which one the dog grabs does he
grabbed a million dollars or does he
grab the hot dog so for all you people
who are floating out there in space your
dog will bring you down to earth real
quick on what value really is okay and
you can do it with a cat not
Schrodinger's cat he's half dead but you
know this is this is uh this is how you
prove to yourself what has value okay
right now we have so much artificial
stuff we're bombarded with so much
information that we lose track of that
which truly has value which is food it's
only it's the only thing that really has
food and you know if tomorrow the stock
market crashes completely money is no
more this fella here you know Bill Gates
is worth as much as Bill Gates okay all
his stock is just bunch of paper that he
can throw away it's worthless junk and
so you got to keep that in mind that you
know it's all contextual his stock is
worth it only if we give it value once
the whole thing falls apart you know all
that has no value whatsoever now some
people will say well Bill if you know
they have these theories about the
so-called Illuminati or rich people in
general that there they've got
presidents and so on they have all these
secret places we're going to where
they're gonna hide together with their
servants you know when the [ __ ] hits the
fan if it does right and so they have
all these preparations there and they're
gonna introduce a new world order a new
new way of doing things in which
everybody is a slave and they're gonna
be the Masters I don't know about that
you know imagine the Queen of England
okay
Queen Liz and
when things get really rough she goes
into her dungeon with her servants okay
and they're all protected down here I
guess the well the whole world collapses
around them is that possible or or is
she doing the right thing there you know
for imagine now her servants they served
her for many years maybe and now they go
down there they have no reason to
respect her anymore to bow down to the
Queen because uh but she gotta bribe him
with money I mean the only thing at that
point that it has any value is food and
you know servant in fact you get it
himself and he doesn't need to bring it
to the Queen so the Queen right there
you know she's in worse shape than she
thinks I mean maybe she becomes the
servant for all we know I mean how she's
gonna compel her servants to serve her
after the whole thing collapses so I
don't know about this New World Order I
mean I think more than likely what's
gonna happen the Liz is something like
this you know maybe her cook who hates
her and just follows orders because
she's the boss you know things might
switch around 180 degrees after the
collapse and good Oh Liz might end up
you know trolling around in her own
backyard you know maybe she's gonna end
up being food maybe for all we know so
you know you gotta think about these
things whether it's really possible for
these the so-called Illuminati to go
down in a basement and have their
servants you know vouch out but for them
and keep serving them and I'm not sure
you're gonna compel them you're how you
gonna compel the army how you gonna
compel anyone without money you know
once once money's gone there is no chain
of command every man's for himself so
you got to think about these things you
know some people say we're I'm gonna
rush to the mountains or maybe they're
already in the mountains one fella says
that he's self-sufficient
in a lot of these people they think
they're you know when the whole thing
collapses you say well I'm just gonna go
with my gun or my bow and arrow gun uh
duh Buffalo or whatever you know out
there now or bears in the in the forests
or in the mountains and they don't
realize that there's gonna be a lot of
competition a lot of people are going to
think of the same thing they're gonna go
out there and hunt whatever animal is
alive you know and they're gonna kill
that animal and suddenly all the animals
are wiped out just like they were in the
Cretaceous they say that the only thing
that more or less survived with anything
smaller than a cat why because you know
t-rex was hungry and he ever have
anything that you find so you know that
was more or less big you know bigger
than a potato chip you know so yeah I
mean there's gonna be competition that's
for one and if you've got a little
garden and you say well I'm just gonna
if the whole thing collapse I'm gonna be
self-sufficient what I'm gonna do is
just grow my own potatoes or or wheat or
whatever well you know you're gonna be
joined by a lot of people you know they
see weed in your house you you better
have some protection and that's what a
lot of people don't understand there's
people who told me oh the Amish you're
gonna survive see because they they're
self-sufficient they they they grow
their own stuff etc etc yeah but what
nobody seems to understand is that the
only issue after the whole thing
collapses is security there's gonna be
no 911 no defense budget okay and so the
issue is you're on your own and when you
have someone come into your territory
you better know how to defend yourself
you're gonna have to defend yourself
against a lot of people out there okay
so keep that in mind the only issues
defense that's the number one issue
without defense you have nothing
whether you are self-sufficient growing
crops or whether you're self-sufficient
hunting out there know if yourself for
sure you're gonna die you got to do this
with the group okay if you're gonna
survive you don't have a group for sure
you're gonna die okay the other thing is
by the way you know also if you're
self-sufficient one of the things that
you're gonna run into as a problem is
when you get sick
you know right now you know like I had
an operation what was in January and it
was nice because they put you to sleep
you don't know anything when you wake up
you're done you know they they fixed you
up whatever the operation you had later
on it's gonna be you know with a knife a
little bit of whiskey and like the
hankie you know that's how it's gonna be
and that's if you have someone else with
you you're all alone forget it yeah
you're gonna have big problems even a
toothache is gonna kill you so yeah keep
in mind all these things defense and
health are number one before food even
okay okay another person made a comment
he said regarding extinction say you
aren't thinking literally and not
cyclically yes we yes food production
goes up and down in cycles okay
the great thing about Humanity is we
have struck a strong drive to take care
of our self-interest
well let's address that first of all you
know all animals are self-interested
they take care of themselves okay so
every living entity every living animal
I would say is self-interested okay so
you said nothing the other one is you
know we had a flow of the mode of
production of how we ran our economics
in the last 200,000 years we were
hunter-gatherers for most of that time
okay and I have a little chart here to
show it gives you an idea and it's one
of my papers that I published and you
can see that we were hunter-gatherers
for at least over a hundred thousand
years for sure and then we went about
ten thousand years ago these are around
numbers okay ten thousand years ago we
went at the farming okay and from there
we went into manufacturing about two
hundred three hundred years ago in the
eighteenth century more or less that's
when we started the process we're still
in that process of converting
farmers into manufacturing in many
countries and from manufacturing into
the last category which is services most
of which is unemployment
okay Services is an unemployment line
item okay and here you can see the
breakdown for the entire planet okay let
me get back in here yeah here you see
the breakdown now this is one site that
I saw you'll see similar sites
everywhere you can go to the CIA
site you can go to the world facts and
you'll see something similar to this so
they're all more or less the same this
is the breakdown from two thousand seven
to two thousand seventeen and what you
see there is that what's growing is
services at the expense of what of
agriculture and manufacturing and this
is global okay so what you're seeing
there okay and that trend was not only
predictable and that's inevitable and
it'll continue in that direction as
smart as we are as humans we can't stop
that you have no power to stop this
people say oh we can do anything now we
can't we can't stop that okay this is
predictable deterministic nothing that
we can do about it and what's causing
this is efficiency we're becoming more
and more efficient in agriculture but
becoming more and more efficient in
manufacturing and so the new workers
that come into the world you know the
new generations they have no other
choice but to go into services and again
like I said the other day most of
services is unemployment it's masked
unemployment okay
finance 20% of the US economy what is
that
it's promises insurance credit banking
it's all problems it's it's nothing you
know someone sings and you say well I
got value because I got something light
so here's the audience are listening to
them they're paying for it what did
anybody in that transaction get but I
got value so yeah I heard a nice music
that made me feel good one day well five
minutes or whatever and the other person
got you know a bigger number in his his
or her bank account okay
Sunday instead of a hundred dollars that
person has
$200 or whatever hey so what did we all
get well we got nothing that's what it
is
we got value as Disneyland economists
would say and he talked about value and
yeah value is uh is nothing hey that's
the way I see it you know I have degree
but just so you know where I'm coming
from on that issue and regarding that
last statement or is it I think it's
this one yeah let me put that back up
here says that food comes in cycles okay
and so here's the population curve for
the last two thousand years more or less
okay and I put the food curve there you
know the only way we can sustain people
is if everybody's got a plate of soup
you know every day so you have to
produce food for ever more population
and so it is not cyclical
it is linear in the sense that it's
spring in proportion to the population
see food is one of those strange
commodities that you can't have too much
of and you can't have too little of okay
food is a Goldilocks commodity it's got
to be just right you have to have the
right amount of food per day per people
per person okay so we got eight billion
people on the planet you have to have
food somehow under table for eight
billion people it's just that simple and
so if the population is growing then
food is growing has to be growing in
order to sustain that population so no
not only out we are not going back to
manufacturing and to agriculture or god
forbid to hunter-gathering right but
likewise we're not we're not gonna have
we're not gonna be producing less and
less food like in a cycle a downward
cycle unless the population collapses
then yes you're gonna produce less food
because you don't need as much food for
fewer people but as long as the
population keeps increasing at a slower
rate as it is now
you're gonna need more food and so no
it's not cyclical in that sense in the
long term it's always going up up up up
up in proportion to the population okay
let's get to a couple things that I
wanted to mention and that's what
science is about science is especially
as it relates to physics okay let's get
this right
it's about mechanisms you got to tell
someone what the mechanism is that
mother nature uses to do her invisible
work we know all the visible stuff we
know how a pulley works we know how the
window broken or brick went through the
window we know how a seesaw works you
know one goes up the other one down
because there's you know one guy pushing
up and the other one down and so on we
know all this stuff because everything
is touchable everything is observable
seeable okay what about the invisible
stuff what about magnetism how does a
magnet work now that's uh that's magic
right because we can't see or touch the
mediator okay so what you have to
explain is the mechanism that mother
nature could be using and you know you
might have a different mechanism can
only tell you what my mechanism my
proposals aren't right the mechanisms I
propose and here's the one for light I
just want you to understand it okay here
you have two atoms they're Quantum
Jumping hey they're expanding and
contracting by doing so they send a the
torkoal rope that's between them okay
that rope is what we're gonna call light
that's the mediator of a light we're
putting a rope there between two atoms
right binds the two atoms physically and
it expands and currently the atoms
expand and contract and what it does is
by doing so they torque the rope and
that torsion is what we call light okay
too difficult or do you think you
understand it okay here's magnetism okay
we have two magnets and you can see the
mechanism we're saying that you have
these threads that come out of the atoms
that form the magnets and these threads
are swinging around
repulsion duh Adam the threads hit each
other and push each other away and in
the case of attraction they both go in
the same direction okay and so they kind
of latch onto each other and that's how
they pull the other magnet so the issue
here is whether you understand the
mechanism that I'm proposing I'm saying
you know repulsion the threads hit
against each other and attraction the
threads swing around in the same
direction both clockwise in this case
and by doing so they latch onto each
other and attract the other magnet okay
that's the mechanism proposing gravity
okay here's gravity okay you have a box
falling to earth okay and you have
different angles the closer it is to
earth and you know here you see it as he
comes down okay more and more threads
fan out a ropes fan out okay The Rose
fan out you have more and more ropes
pulling the closer the boxes to earth
because every atom of the earth is tied
to every atom of that box okay that's
that's the theory that's the mechanism
that's being proposed you can see that
there's different amount of ropes when
the box is closer to the earth and
that's what we call weight okay weight
is a location specific parameter okay
and here's a static version of that also
you can see when I'm proposing they're
essentially okay when uh two objects are
far apart the ropes come together they
form a single coaxial so to speak so
gravity is weak and when the two I've
just come closer and closer together the
ropes fan out because all atoms are
interconnected okay and even and closer
like in the case of the last case there
the ropes are completely wide open the
through objects clash okay and this does
explain Newton's equation Newton's
famous gravitation equation if I see
that factor mass one mass two over
distance square
the longer the distance the lower the
force and shorter the distance the
greater the force and there you see it
in in a new Illustrated okay so no so
the question is whether you understand
it okay okay let's move on I've got I
think another one here yeah electricity
what is auto tricity okay here it is it
okay you have the standard version of
electricity which is the flow of
electron beads from atom to atom the
electron is treated as a little bead
that somehow orbits or is somewhere
around the nucleus the quantum mechanics
version gets rid of the atom altogether
just sends beads across doesn't need any
atoms whatsoever that's the quantum
version and then the rope version is
serpentine that twirls in place okay all
the atoms are interconnected they're
physically meshed into each other there
they're blended into each other the the
threads that form the electron shell are
blended and the whole thing twirls like
a drill bit and here you see the
difference in a different format so that
you can see the quantum version official
version is gun shooting bullets that's
how you make holes and rope model is a
drill bit twirling in place and that's
how we make holes they and this is a way
of comparing mechanisms especially when
you're doing the slit experiment okay so
the question people have is bill I don't
see any ropes can't touch any ropes what
are you talking about I don't see you
touch them and so I don't believe in
your ropes ear relevant irrelevant right
now we're in concern about one thing and
one thing only do you understand the
mechanism did you understand the
mechanism you can revise this later on
if you want
do you understand the mechanism of light
what I'm proposing for light do you
understand the mechanism of magnetism
physically how one magnet attracts
another do you understand the mechanism
of gravity how the ropes fan out as a
bus or whatever falls to earth make it
be an astronaut or someone falling from
an airplane do you understand the
mechanism of electricity do you
understand the mechanism do you
visualize they have you grasp that first
and if the answer is yes if the answer
is no oh then you need to have
clarification on that because if the
mechanism is incorrect if it doesn't
explain what happens out there there's
no need to answer any other question
okay because if the mechanism fails you
know there's no need to continue it with
any kind of questions the only reason a
person would ask more questions is if he
concedes that yeah that mechanism does
work for gravity for magnetism you know
have I mimicked the mechanisms and if
the answer is yes then we have then I
get to ask the next question first okay
and that question is can quantum
mechanics do the same thing can it
rationally explain those invisible
mechanisms with their particles because
I don't want you going back to quantum
mechanics if I can't answer a question
for example we got to make sure we get
rid of quantum mechanics the the
explanations the physical
interpretations of quantum mechanics
first and so let's get rid of that first
if quantum mechanics can explain the
mechanism fine but for sure they can't
you know it's it's all your rational
explanations coming out of quantum
mechanics that's why all these guys like
Richard Feynman and Leo Susskind you
know they say they don't even understand
their own theories and they'll never
understand it we just do science which
is a process whatever that is you know
and we just investigate never find we'll
never figure it out that's what they
tell and so so let's get that clear
first first question is do you
understand the mechanism and if you do
the second question is can quantum
explain the same mechanisms with
particles with discrete particles or
waves waves should not be in there
because quantum uses the wave as a
crutch
you know when they can't explain it what
particles they do well let me explain
the slit experiment or Compton's the
Compton effect with waves or whatever
you know anyway they twist it around and
yeah no you have to if you can't explain
polarization for example you you can't
go back to waves and say well now I'm
gonna turn my particle into a wave to
explain this that's a cop-out that means
they you know they're they're using
things they're using an ad hoc thing
mediator to do they're they're different
explanations and again yeah anybody can
do you know explain anything that way
when you just turn you know a rock into
a sponge or whatever yeah they say well
here I'm gonna explain with a sponge and
here I need the rock and over there I
need a stick you know what is this you
just change things as you need them you
know that means they don't have an
explanation that's it and that's why
they claim that they don't understand
they can't give you a physical
interpretation okay here more comments
that were made along these lines having
to do with light and some of the
mechanisms okay here's the first comment
said how does the rope model attack
Bell's Theorem the quantum Venn diagram
paradox okay and it's related
specifically to polarization I'm not
gonna go over that here but I'll just
say that there is an answer and you can
find it in the book the rope hypothesis
if you can download it over there for
free rope hypothesis comm and if you go
to pages 132 133 it's titled
extra-credit polarization you'll get an
idea of how how the a third polarizer
inserted between two reestablishes the
the
the beam of light partially okay and
incidentally I just want to mention that
you know quantum doesn't have an
explanation for this either what they do
is again that what they're trying to
what they try to do is they turn their
particles into ways okay and you say
okay so we have a wave well not really
what you're looking at over there those
arrows those are not [ __ ] arrows okay
those are vectors and what they've done
in in mathematics is uh they did a
little cartoon that's what you're
staring at and it's a cartoon because
what you're looking at those arrows are
really vectors what is a vector vector
has magnitude and direction that's why
the vectors are pointing up or sideways
and what they do they put all these
vectors there one side of beside the
other and all that Scott is just a
magnitude okay and they're pointing and
they turn this into something that's
movable and you think you're looking at
a wave so called wave a wave of what a
wave of vectors what is a vector a
number of value that's all it is it's
just a quantity and what you're looking
at quantities that are moving you're
looking at number five and six and seven
that are moving in front of your eyes
that's what you're staring at and that's
what they call a wave so be aware of
what you do not be fooled when you look
at this and think that you're looking at
a physical entity you're not what you're
looking at is a bunch of numbers that
these guys have going from A to B yay
and that's how they try to explain some
of these things when actually they
haven't given a physical interpretation
because they don't have anything
physical in front of your eyes but you
think you're you have something physical
because you see something flowing in
front of your eyes and you say oh yeah
it's the wave no no there is no such
thing as a wave there is no such thing
as a field okay anyone using the word
field is a religious fanatic there is no
physical object called field there is no
physical object called wave wave and
feel they're both dynamic concepts you
can't move concepts in physics okay you
can do it in religion at your Sunday
School not in physics yeah you can't say
you're gonna move information you gotta
transfer energy you're going to
warp time those are you know that
languages for mathematics you know those
those people do magic all the time okay
here's another fellow and he asked
question and though something like that
is why can't we see the ropes famous see
touch connecting each atom of Earth to
other planets in and galaxies I'm asking
this question because quantity of ropes
that formed magnet is very less than the
quantity present between earth and other
planets okay so he has this inquiry as
doubt this thing that's going on his
mind well the first issue people have a
hard time understanding is today we
don't have a definition of the word
object from the mathematical world
mathematical physics mathematics there
is no definition of the word object
because mathematical physics doesn't
deal with objects mathematical physics
only is interested in equations in
numbers in describing so they don't have
explanations they don't have mechanisms
that's why they can't answer qualitative
type of questions people are not
familiar with that issue it's a very
important issue because every time
someone goes out there you know a layman
he wants to know how this universe works
so he's not gonna ask you give me the
equation for this or this or that what
is einstein's field equation what is
Schrodinger's equation no they don't ask
those type of questions people ask how
does this work and the other guy answers
with a description involving equations
and this guy said ok ok and just goes
away because he didn't understand squat
and and that's the issue you'll never
find a physical interpretation a
qualitative physical interpretation to a
mechanism to an invisible mechanism such
as gravity and magnetism you won't find
it but you'll find is mathematical
description they'll give you a lot of
word and verbiage there
and if you understood fine otherwise
they'll tell you whether you should
study math at the college level and then
you'll understand and then you'll
understand the same thing as them they
won't be able to if they can't explain
it you you would have lost your time
going to college try to learn the same
nonsense that they learned because all
they can do is describe so we're back to
square one they have no explanations
okay and so what's the issue with the
ropes well the issue of the ropes is
that we start with the definition and
the word object is defined as that which
has shape so there is no group no
provision for see or touch or smell or
hearing or taste you can't say why can't
ice taste the Rope why can't I smell the
Rope why can't I hear the rope
no no because that's not the definition
of what an object is an object is that
which has shape and a rope does have
shape do you see something with shape
here
that's a rope okay so ropes have shape
okay so we met the condition of of the
definition the definition is that you
have to mediate mother nature's secret
agents you know you have the medium
mediate them with object you have to
have a physical mediator what is
physical what is an object what is a
mediator it's that which has shape not
that which you can touch not that which
you can see not every object is seeable
you can't see the air for example and
not every object is touchable and until
you grabs that really in your hand you
know these questions go are are
worthless you know because people have
to understand the definition of the word
object of the mediator that mother
nature uses is not touched Percy the
criterion is shape it's got to have a
couple guys gave me a different verse
and says how about contour how bad was
it they can't remember the other words
now something like perimeter I can't
remember the other words anyways you
refer just to the outline okay
right now I have no counter-argument to
that I think they're all synonyms but
maybe someone smarter than me will
figure it out
okay right now I'm accepting all those
because you know shape contour perimeter
you know all these referring to the
outline of an object okay as long as
it's got that and the contrast was
another one I propose there's got to be
contrast you know because otherwise you
know you don't have an object you have
an infinite object which is irrational
so you know I think all those are
synonyms right now I have no
counter-argument to that okay so again
if someone smarter me in computer out
anyways these are types of irrational
questions that people ask okay they put
it over here read them out real quick
okay and and the first thing that you
have to note that you can't ask a
question of purpose and reason reasons
right in the context of physics physics
deals with causes and mechanisms and
let's get this right okay physics deals
with causes and mechanisms philosophy
deals with reasons and purpose purposes
okay so when someone asks questions like
you you see some of those they're at the
bottom from a to I why is there
something rather than nothing it's an
irrational question what you're asking
already is saying oh that God made this
what was his purpose for making this why
is there something right well I don't
know God had a headache I don't know
maybe got the coronaviruses decided to
make something instead of nothing I mean
you're asking a question of purpose and
reason reasons in in the context of
physical causes and mechanisms and
people don't always understand where's
the speed of light 300,000 kilometers
per second well I guess I can put there
God mother nature father universe and
the double you know wished it to be so
that's the answer to those questions why
does time seem to flow in only one
direction
well time doesn't flow time is a concept
so you can't say that time flows in any
direction there is no such thing as time
okay and so you can't you can't use that
word as a physical object and see how
does time flow like a river kind of time
is that there is no physical object
called time hey you got to talk about
the things that move you can say a lion
moves and you clock them that's
different than saying time flows and
that's not time that's when it's a lion
that's flowing or a river or whatever
why is gravity so weird well weird is an
opinion so we don't care about that how
is how did the universe begin well
that's irrational you can't convert
something into nothing or nothing into
something unless you know the mechanism
and you can explain the mechanism that's
an irrational question what is the
vacuum made out of vacuum is nothing
it's a synonym of zero of zip of nothing
zero emptiness whatever you want to call
it okay there are different words for
that synonyms and so the vacuum is
nothing you can't say what is it made of
is it made of something that's a
contradiction because nothing is the
opposite of something you can't say what
is nothing made of okay you just gotta
define the word and we define vacuum as
that which has no shape if something is
that which has shaped nothing is that
which has no shape they are antonyms now
we can use them consistently in a
presentation in a dissertation okay
what's outside of infinite space I don't
know more infinity what is an elementary
fundamental entity made oh well if it's
elementary fundamental means that it's
not by definition it's not made of
anything so you can't say well what does
that made of yeah it's it's an
irrational question people are always
understand what does a black hole look
like well the zero dimensional nothing
doesn't look like anything you know and
so they they put a picture of a black
hole people see all the first black hole
no no you can't take a picture of a
black hole because in ceará that
mentioned you know that was proven
mathematically by mr. Chandrasekhar who
got a Nobel Prize for proving that black
hole is zero dimensional people are not
always aware of that that you know it's
been already settled black hole zero
dimensional general dimensional mean
notes
I know volume I don't know what that
looks like now you tell me looks like
pretty much like nothing that's what it
looks like so until people get these
things they're you know they keep asking
these irrational questions because they
don't understand where the contradiction
is and the contradiction is in language
specifically but also in you know and
how these things are interpreted okay
today I want to talk specifically about
this individual who has a couple videos
online and he misleads a lot of people
you can see there he's got these five
hundred sixty five hundred sixty
thousand hits okay and he's from
Fermilab and his bozo known as Don
Lincoln he talks nonsense and I would
exposed this guy and I think we should
this is a ridicule these people first
because they make a lot of money on your
at your expense they the Fermilab is
maintained by the US government and so
you know taxpayer money that's what pays
for this bulletin to talk nonsense and
that's why I'd like to ridicule them and
I want these people out of science
they're not scientists there are
religious fanatics and they have no
explanations for things simple as light
okay and that's what I want to expose
today okay so here here is summary of
why this fella talks nonsense okay and
I'm gonna go through each one of these
okay let me put this here to the side
and we'll go step-by-step here first of
all this individual he invokes what is
Niels Bohr and Ernst Roth of Forbes a
planetary model of the atom that's the
model that they use in quantum mechanics
to this day they use it at CERN the
Large Hadron Collider they use it at
SLAC the Stanford Linear Accelerator and
also at Fermilab all these places they
they use they use the planetary model of
the atom and here it is this is from
their site by the way I'm not putting
words in their mouth here because this
is this is the
they show let me show you here yeah you
see it that's the atom that's the atom
they're gonna use okay what is it a
bunch of beads those by the way are not
wires
those those ellipses there those are
supposedly the trajectories you know the
contrails if you can if you will of the
electron bead as it goes around the atom
so they always draw them because if you
take them out you wouldn't understand
the picture
if they take those wires out of there so
they leave the wires in there and you
think you're looking at an atom okay so
this is the atom that that Fermilab is
going to use this fellow that's going to
use okay so there we have our first
problem okay what other problems do we
have well the second one is orbiting
electron bead moves in transverse waves
you know one of the reasons they never
illustrate these things because they
can't and I'll show that in a second
here you can't illustrate you cannot
illustrate all imaginary a prism okay
it's got all these atoms that form the
prism and you have within each atom you
have all these electron beads are going
around in every direction right that's
that's what quantum mechanics proposes
and these guys are saying you know that
all those electrons that are going
around their atoms they're not coming
out of the atoms there's no ionization
and there is no electricity all we have
is just a solid there you know prism you
know and light comes in there and so how
do they explain the slowing down of
light through this prism which suddenly
they claim that slows light down all the
way they explain is here all these
electrons form a wave and the waves is
slower than the incoming wave of light
and so it slows down the wave of light
that's that's their explanation
so let's see if we can visualize first
okay before we continue see if we can
visualize this
electron wave the waves of the electrons
okay I tried to make it illustrate this
thing you tell me if I succeeded it is
okay I want you to tell me how the all
those atoms that form the prism right
the electron beams that are going around
the nucleus how that turns into a
Fermilab wave which is how there you can
explain the slowing down of light I mean
how does the guy in the left become the
one on the right how do you make a
transverse wave that moves in one
direction and slows the wave of light
remember number one is the wave of the
electron wave number two is the the red
one is supposedly the one of light and
then the third one is the summation of
these two okay that's that's their
argument this is out of their website
okay and the question is how does that
the electron beads of the prism equal
number one which is a very slow-moving
wave okay as you can see it's new moving
very slowly yeah I mean you cannot even
conceptualize it you cannot visualize
what they're saying and that's why they
never draw it
they never illustrate this stuff because
it's uh astray table you cannot
illustrate this okay
but I don't plan to hold my breath but
it's up to them they have to illustrate
it I did my best that's that's the way I
see it I cannot illustrate what they're
saying but maybe they're smarter than me
I don't know okay light is a waving
electric field this is what they say
okay but field is a bunch of vectors
magnitude and direction
and here's proof those people who like
proof in evidence here we have proof in
evidence okay we go to the definition we
find at least in the Wikipedia you can
find other sources you'll find something
very similar it says field is a physical
quantity what is the quantity is that a
physical object and you hold a quantity
in your hand now you can hold the potato
in your hand you can hold the bag of
potatoes you might have ten potatoes
that's a quantity of 10 you don't hold
10 but you hold this potatoes
people are saying field is a quantity
okay that's in for the purposes of so
called physics mathematical physics that
has value for each point in space-time
in other words it's a concept that's
what field is it's a constant abstract
concept and this is what they're gonna
wave they move it up and down this
concept yeah they're gonna move love
they can move information they're gonna
move intelligence up and down they're
moving concepts around and in
mathematics you know they have a field
as a set now what is a set well that's
got to do with mathematics if for those
who took math you'll know what I mean
it's just a collection that's it of
whatever and so that again a collection
is not a physical object okay so that's
the starting point for the debunking the
field notion but here is here's what
they show this is what a feel would what
they show for light okay you have two
fields the electric and magnetic field
what are you staring at a bunch of
vectors if you look those arrows again
are not in Janeiro's what you're those
arrows point to our quantum magnitude
and direction that's what they have what
is that that's a number line though what
you're seeing is a bunch of number lines
that are flowing they they turn this
into a something physical or something
that you can see so that you get fooled
into believing that you're staring at
something that is physical when it's not
what you see is a bunch of con sucks
okay that's what that is okay what's the
next one does that explain the physical
mechanism of wave interaction see is
that is the photon a physical entity
does it have sizes that have mass all
this other stuff and here you can see
what I'm talking about okay I try to
illustrate this and this is also using
your stuff okay I'm not putting words in
their mouth what you're seeing is what
they put they say we've got these waves
okay fine we got the waves what are
those ways are those waves just a string
is it a rope is it
what are we looking at and the question
is okay whatever that is how do they
interact they're not telling you how
those two waves are physically
interacting they just say look if you
add though number one plus number two
you get number three that's all they're
saying and what you're seeing there is
again amplitude and not anything related
to light you're not even seeing a
standing way because the only reason
that gives you the sensation of being a
standing wave is that it's a straight
across in other words horizontal somehow
it doesn't fall
what is it the weight fall down you know
and I showed that the other day let's
even give myself back up here show that
the other day you know here if I don't
hang on to to this on the other end here
that's that's what we should be seeing
the wave should fall if nothing is
supporting the wave or if the wave is
not attached at the other end and these
people do this artificially they have
this like a stake and going like that
without anyone holding the other end why
does that wave stay straight more or
less straight you know why does it flow
horizontally without it falling you know
since especially when they claim also
that gravity affects light so we got a
lot of problems there in their physical
interpretations okay does he think yeah
here's the summary again let me get it
up there okay what's the next one states
that light does not encounter electron
ways when it leaves the water or the
prism they have two videos one for water
and one for class and there are prisms
made of glass so prism is a valid word
there as well they don't do prism maybe
I know why I'll talk about that in a
second here but here here you see what I
showed a couple times ago there is air
all around a piece of glass or a prism
or whatever so you have the red waves
there that are the electron waves
supposedly which we cannot imagine
they have to illustrate them to tell us
what they're really talking about and
then you have the waves of light they're
going through the piece of glass but the
the waves come from air go through the
glass and then go back out into air so
they do encounter atoms they do
encounter electron waves also in air and
so the question is you know they never
explain why why light when it goes out
of the prism right you know it does it
doesn't counter atoms and electron waves
as well why does it slow down there so
they haven't explained the interaction
between the air molecules and light they
have not explained that okay they they
have to show that and it'd be nice if
they made a video of that so that we
could see their mechanism what they're
proposing of course they can't do that
they can't do that because they're their
whole interpretation is nonsense that's
why they can't do it okay and here we
have their explanation they say that the
electric field of the atoms you know
there's the electrons of the atoms in
the glass slowed down the light going
through air and all it is is just a
mathematical thing there is no physical
interpretation what they do is just put
a bunch of arrows there they don't they
don't show the the waves they don't show
the interaction between waves but they
just do is just say look there's an
electric field that opposes the incoming
light the light that comes from the air
into the glass okay and they say look
all these electrons they move them
around okay and they say that they've
got the electrons on the wrong side
that's fine that doesn't matter because
right now we don't know are they saying
that all these atoms really align and
how do they form waves and even if they
do that then what is the interaction
between the light coming into the glass
and the electron waves the alleged
electron
wave that opposes that incoming wave
front ok so there's there is no physical
interpretation not not from from these
folks and until they draw it until they
illustrate it you know we don't have any
idea what they're talking about let's
see if there was something else I don't
have to say about that yeah here's
another issue and that's I brought this
up that you know if if if light comes
into a prism it breaks into color white
light right when it goes out if there is
nothing to prevent it like they say that
there are no atoms or electrons or
anything out there like if they do this
in outer space
well then we should have white light
coming back out again you know why do we
still have colors I mean what you really
get is not this you get this other one
give me a second here see if we can get
it up here this is what you get okay
when you do the experiment again
something like that you get colors
coming out and they're prediction to use
that word is this that you should have
white light coming back out because now
light returns to its original speed that
it had before it went into the prism
okay so they have a series of problems
with their explanations okay and last
but not these we have that they confuse
amplitude for speed now I think that was
the big one because that's what they
were trying to prove with the video and
here's a bozo Lincoln again who makes a
lot of money more money than he deserves
and I like to ridicule these guys and
this is what he's saying and I want you
to pay close attention to that red arrow
on your right if you look at the wave
the wave at the top is the electron wave
the red one and number two is the light
wave and the third one is the wave that
it goes through the prism in other words
it goes slower according to them because
the blue electron wave slows the red
light wave down somehow they don't show
the interaction they just say it is so
and these are their words that why don't
you read they're on the bottom it says
let's go here when one wave is moving at
a different speed than the other one
the result is a different way that's all
they say you'll hear this is the entire
mechanism but one that has a different
speed than either of the two if we add
the two top waves mathematics which have
different speeds the bottom wave also
moves but slower and you can see that's
not the case because when you look at
the word the red arrow is now when it
starts again the two waves are moving at
the same speed okay but what this guy is
confusing is amplitude which is the up
and down you know the height of the
weighed the all we're doing is making
the wave go higher so when you look at
it closely all he's doing is doing
amplitude he calls this speed he
confuses amplitude with speed and that's
the mechanism that these so-called
professionals Authority right are
proposing for white light goes slower
through a prism or through glass or
through any denser medium than air like
water for example so you'd be the judge
you go and verify run your own test
reach your own conclusions if you like
to swallow an authority because you
simply conclude that all these geniuses
cannot be wrong no fine I mean I can't
do anything about that
all I'm saying I'm all I can do is
present my case show you that these guys
have no idea whatsoever what they're
talking about you do have people like
fine money even Neil spoor and Susskind
more modern today you know all these
people saying they don't understand
their own theories no one believes them
they say no of course you understand
your theory otherwise we wouldn't have
computers we wouldn't have GPS and
that's what people having in their mind
ignorant people having their minds no
these people don't understand the theory
they will never understand the theory
because they're using the wrong mediator
particles you can't do physics with
particles discrete particles because you
can't get them to move in the first
place
how do you move other discreet bead that
forms the ether or that forms some kind
of particle from quantum how do you get
it to move in the first place why does
it move the only way you're gonna get it
to move is another one bumps into it why
did that one move and so so again they
do it with bumps one hitting yellow and
then hitting the other one where's this
first bump coming from from you know
outside of space-time who's pushing the
first the first particle that's the
issue so you can talk about pressure you
can talk about a lot of nonsense and and
what you need to do is explain what what
causes that pressure what is the origin
of that it's like trying to explain what
causes motion to begin with good luck
with that one anyways if I'm not too
sick I guess I'll see you on Sunday I'm
losing a little bit of my voice may be
coming down with hopefully just a
regular call maybe not the corona virus
but we'll see if by a Sunday so we'll
see you then
see you on Sunday bye buddy have a good
day bye-bye